ومعنا من شمال غزه الصحفي عماد زقوت عماد
لو ترصد لنا المشهد من شمال
القطاع نعم المشهد هو تواصل المدفعيه
الاسرائيليه في اطلاق القذائف منذ فجر
اليوم حتى هذه اللحظه اتجاه مناطق متفرقه
من شمال قطع غزه وكذلك المسيرات العسكريه
الاسرائيليه هي تواصل التحليق بشكل مكثف
في هذه
الاجواء الليله الماضيه استهدفت الطيرات
المسيره الاسرائيليه مجموعه من المواطن
بالقرب من مدخل بيت حنون شمال قطع غزه
وادى الى استشهاد خمسه مواطنين واصابه
اخرين في هذه المنطقه التي تم استهدافها
بطائرات مسيره عسكريه اسرائيليه المقاومه
الفلسطينيه تحديدا كتاب القسام اعلنت عن
اسقاط لطائره
مسي منطقه تل الزعتر والتي كانت تجوب
الاجواء في هذه المنطقه تم اسقاطها وتم
الاعلان عنها من قبل كتائب القسام في
منطقه الصفطاوي وهو حي الصفطاوي الذي يقع
الى الغرب من جباليا وهذا الحي الذي على
مدار الايام الاخيره تعرض لعمليه عسكريه
اسرائيليه مركزه تم من خلالها وحسب شهود
عيان وحسب الذين اتوا من هذه المنطقه تم
تفجير عدد كبير من الابراج في هذه المنطقه
هي عباره عن عمارات كبيره تتكون من عمارات
كبيره هذا الحي حي الصفطاوي حسب شهد ان
جنود الاحتلال والاليات العسكريه
الاسرائليه هي فخخ عدد كبير من هذه
الابراج وتم
تفجيرها في هذه المنطقه تحديدا ايضا تم
اعتقال العشرات من المواطنين تحديدا
الشبان في هذه المنطقه وايضا تم طرد وتم
نقلهم الى موقع عسكري في في زكيم الذي يقع
الى شمال الغربي من بيت لاهيا وبعد الفحص
ايضا تم طرد ما يقرب من اكثر اثر من 200
مواطن بالملابس الداخليه الليله الماضيه
وهم بالملابس الداخليه وتم ترحيلهم الى
مخيم جباليا ووصلوا الى هذه المنطقه الي
نحن نتواجد فيها في مخيم جباليا باوضاع
نفسيه واوضاع صعبه هذا ما يتعلق بحي
الصفطاوي ولحتى هذه اللحظه هنالك تواجد
للاليات العسكريه في هذه المنطقه كذلك
الاليات العسكريه تتواجد في المناطق
الغربيه ل جباليا النزله
وكذلك الشرق من جباليا البلد ماتعلق ب
الوضع المعيشي ربما هنا الوضع جراء منع
وصول المساعدات الانسانيه منذ فترات زمنيه
بعيده الوضع هنا المعيشي صعب اليوم هو
اليوم جمعه اليوم الثان الجمعه الثانيه عش
لهذه الحرب الاسرائيليه على قطع غزه الوضع
هنا معيشي صعب المياه شحيحه وكذلك الوضع
البيئي والامراض التي تنتشر بين الناس دا
في مدارس الايواء هنالك اوضاع صحيه صعبه
وانتشار لامراض جلديه في هذه المدارس
وانتشار كبير للقمامه نتيجه
تدمير البلديات في شمال قطع غزه والشلل
كامل لهذه البلديات وكذلك وكاله الغوث
التي هي اصلا لا تتواجد في شمال قطع غزه
هذه الاوضاع المعيشيه والبيئيه والصحيه في
شمال قطع غزه تزداد صعوبه يوما بعد يوم
وقد تنتشر اوبئه بشكل كبير بين الناس
وتحديدا الاطفال والنساء نتيجه الازدحام
ونتيجه الوضع الصحي الصعب في مدارس الاواء
على مستوى ايضا الميداني كما تحدثنا
الاليات العسكريه هي الان هي تتواجد في
المناطق الشرقيه والشماليه ل حنون وكذلك
الشرقيه لجبال والمناطق الغربيه لجبال
النزله ومنطقه الصفطاوي وهي تتعرض للعمليه
العسكريه وتفجير ابراج في هذه المنطقه في
حي الصفو عماد زقوت مراسل او الصحفي
الفلسطيني كنت معنا من شمال غزه شكرا
جزيلا